[Music]
as you're going through your work
whether at home or at the office or
anywhere where you're part of a process
where you're trying to get something
done it's very useful at least every
once in a while to ask yourself why am I
doing this so if I'm doing something to
benefit other people to make their work
easier are they actually taking
advantage of it if I'm writing a summary
of what I just created is anybody using
that summary because maybe at one time
somebody used the summary but no one's
using it now or maybe I just started
doing this and assume that it was useful
to other people but they aren't actually
using it maybe I've created work that
doesn't actually need to be done now
sometimes too we want to make things
more beautiful than they need to be now
beautiful tools make work of joy and it
is more pleasurable to work with files
when the files are neat and organized or
when the binders all match and are all
lined up and and look great absolutely
but there is a point where that can
swallow us up we can spend too much time
on things that are too fleeting or that
don't really go to the aim that we're
trying to achieve and you want to think
about what if people are just gonna be
using these binders for like 10 minutes
do I really want to spend 30 minutes
making them look right sometimes the
answer might be it's totally worth it
but sometimes maybe we could use some
kind of more makeshift solution it might
get us where we need to go and save us a
lot of time and energy because what we
want to do as we're creating outer order
is we really want to be purposeful with
our time and our energy and our
possessions we want to do the things
that matter that do the things that take
us where we want to go and to create the
environment in which we want to live but
we don't want to let ourselves get
consumed or choked with tasks that
really in the end don't need to be done
at all
you